fto fire says what's up with all these
frog occurrences I've never seen such
synchronicity man I don't know what to
say about that I had some frog
synchronicity occurrences earlier this
year that just about made me faint so I
don't know I have I I have no idea what
to make of it
you know I it leaves me speechless now
that's all I can say about that you know
I I do young it Carl Jung had some
strange ideas and and one of them was
synchronicity you know the fact that
things could line up in a way that
seemed meaningful and you know much as I
don't understand how that occurs I've
experienced it many many times and in
very convincing ways and so it's it's
one of the things that leads me to think
that the world isn't structured the way
that we think it is I think it's
structured more like a symphony where
we're and there are times when discs
different parts of the world different
parts of being can come into harmony
spontaneously and and all point in the
same direction and why that happens I
have no idea I don't understand it at
all